seguramente están familiarizados con
algunas formas en las que se presenta el
carbono como por ejemplo el grafito que
tenemos aquí esta es una forma en la que
podemos encontrar el carbono y es muy
importante cuando usamos un lápiz al
deslizar el grafito sobre el papel sin
el carbono no podríamos escribir y bueno
el papel no es carbono puro pero también
tiene carbono y miren por acá tenemos un
diamante puro una forma que el carbono
puede adoptar después de mucho tiempo
bajo presiones muy altas pero de lo que
tal vez no se han dado cuenta es de que
el carbono es esencial para la vida de
hecho la vida como la conocemos está
basada en el carbono el carbono es la
base de la vida cuando buscamos vida en
otros planetas se busca vida basada en
el carbono tal vez la vida puede existir
en otros elementos pero sólo hay uno que
hemos podido analizar
ahora porque el carbono es tan valioso
para la vida porque forma parte de las
moléculas que hacen que la vida sea
posible bueno todo se resume al lugar
que ocupa en la tabla periódica su
número atómico y su tendencia a formar
enlaces por esto es que la química es
tan importante verán el carbono tiene un
número atómico de 6 eso significa que
tiene 6 protones entonces si dibujamos
el núcleo
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 protones y el
isótopo más común del carbono en la
tierra es el carbono 12 que también
tiene 6 neutrones vamos a dibujarlo 1 2
3 4 5 6 y claro el carbono neutro tiene
6 electrones 2 de ellos se encuentran en
la primera capa electrónica aquí tenemos
los primeros 2 electrones podemos decir
que esta es la capa interna
pues los cuatro electrones restantes se
encuentran en la capa externa a estos
cuatro electrones les vamos a llamar
electrones de valencia porque son los
electrones que reacciona si algo de esto
les parece desconocido los invito a que
vean más vídeos en khan academy sobre
los electrones de valencia porque este
vídeo es más como un resumen entonces el
carbono tiene 4 electrones de valencia y
los electrones de valencia son los que
reaccionan o producen la reacción pero
vamos a simplificar este dibujo podemos
decir ok el carbono para registrar sus
electrones de valencia el carbono tiene
1 2 3 4 electrones de valencia ahora tal
vez recuerden la regla del octeto como
los átomos tienden a ser más estables
cuando pretenden que tienen o que
comparten 8 electrones en su última capa
de electrónica aquí el carbono puede
lograr eso al formar cuatro enlaces
covalentes
por ejemplo con hidrógeno este hidrógeno
tiene un electrón de valencia bueno de
hecho sólo tiene un electrón así que el
hidrógeno se siente feliz al tener dos
electrones porque así siente que ha
llenado su primera capa de electrónica y
se parece al el entonces el carbono que
comparte este electrón puede volver a
hacerlo con otro hidrógeno de nuevo con
otro hidrógeno y nuevamente con otro
hidrógeno ahora el carbono dice hey
estoy compartiendo los electrones y cada
uno de los hidrógenos dice oh mira estoy
compartiendo dos electrones todos son
felices son estables y miren esta
molécula es el metano
este es el metano por definición como
involucra al carbono se considera una
molécula orgánica se considera una
molécula
de hecho todo el campo de química
orgánica se dedica a estudiar moléculas
orgánicas es decir moléculas que
contienen carbono
ahora como esta molécula sólo tiene
carbono e hidrógeno podemos decir que es
un hidrocarburo hidrocarburo
tal vez ya están familiarizados con
algunas cosas como la gasolina la
gasolina es un hidrocarburo y tanto la
gasolina como el metano son usados como
combustible y bueno normalmente podemos
encontrar cadenas muy largas de
hidrocarburos por ejemplo podemos tener
una cadena de 8 carbonos que forma un
octano si han llegado a escuchar que hay
combustible con alto octanaje vamos a
ver un carbono 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
este es un hidrocarburo llamado octano
porque tiene 8 carbonos por eso es ok
octano y todos los demás enlaces
recuerden el carbono forma cuatro
enlaces así que este carbono tiene
cuatro enlaces este carbono también
tiene cuatro enlaces este carbono
también tiene dos con hidrógenos y dos
con carbonos dos con carbono
2 con hidrógenos espero que esto les
ayude a entender por qué el carbono es
un elemento tan importante el carbono
puede formar muchos enlaces con
diferentes estructuras y estos
hidrocarburos pueden ser cadenas o
incluso se pueden formar anillos
compuestos cíclicos y en cosas como el
grafito y el diamante los carbonos
forman redes en las que el carbono está
unido a más de 2 carbonos haciendo
formas tridimensionales ahí está y como
el carbono forma cuatro enlaces
generalmente tiene una geometría tetra
erika cuando alguien dice tetraedro se
refiere a usaré otro color un tetraedro
es una figura en tres dimensiones que
tiene cuatro caras formadas por
triángulos cada cara es un triángulo se
ve así y podemos verlo como una pirámide
de base triangular entonces cuando el
carbono forma enlaces digamos que en el
caso del metano
aquí tenemos el carbono del centro y
después cada uno de estos hidrógenos se
encuentran en las esquinas o mejor dicho
en los vértices del tetraedro esta es la
geometría te trae drica que forma el
carbono y vamos a dibujar los enlaces
covalentes aquí tenemos uno que
corresponde a este después tenemos este
por acá los electrones se están moviendo
después tenemos otro por acá y
finalmente tenemos uno por acá entonces
el metano puede que lo encuentren
dibujado así pero en realidad tiene la
forma de un te traer aquí tenemos
hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno
y cada una de estas líneas representa un
par de electrones así que tenemos 8
electrones que están siendo compartidos
pero no olviden que en la realidad es
algo más parecido a esto
ahora como les decía el carbono es un
elemento esencial para la vida como la
conocemos incluso es la base de la vida
como nosotros somos la forma que tenemos
ya hemos hablado de que todos somos en
su mayoría agua si analizamos a los
seres humanos podemos decir que en
promedio
somos 65% oxígeno eso quiere decir que
somos dos tercios de oxígeno por toda el
agua que tenemos recuerden que el agua
es h2o y el oxígeno conforma la parte
más voluminosa de la molécula de agua
pero en segundo lugar tenemos carbono el
carbono es aproximadamente el 18 por
ciento de la masa de nuestro cuerpo así
que en todas las partes que no fluyen es
decir en todas las partes de nuestro
cuerpo que no se encuentran en estado
líquido podemos encontrar un montón de
carbón por ejemplo esta es la molécula
de adn
y todas estas pequeñas áreas grises son
carbono por acá tenemos exo quinasa no
entraré en muchos detalles pero la exo
quinasa es una proteína y todo lo que
vemos de color verde a su lado es carbón
por acá tenemos glucosa que es muy
importante para regular la energía de
nuestro cuerpo y todo lo verde a su lado
es carbono y después tenemos atp que es
fundamental para la obtención de energía
celular igualmente todo lo verde a su
lado es carbón por eso es que el carbono
forma una parte muy importante de todo
lo que no es líquido en nuestro cuerpo
espero que esto les dé una mejor idea de
que el carbono no solamente es útil para
cosas como el grafito y los diamantes
sino que también al simplemente observar
nuestras manos estamos viendo un montón
de carbón